let's thank that I guess okay and let's
wear come the last speaker before the
panel and set then before you get your
drinks and food so this will be
Alessandro a Christie from CMU who's
also visiting with Travis's and he will
talk about privacy in the age of
augmented reality
buona sera Thank You Christian afro
Carnegie Mellon University and I'm
delighted to be visiting microsoft
research this term I mean economist by
training I I call what I do the
economics and behavioral economics of
privacy it's a combination of economics
behavior decision research and data
mining and in the next seven minutes or
so I'll tell you everything you know you
need to know about these three areas now
in fact I will try even to up and fail
in doing so okay who presented six grade
professions in a minute i'll try to span
two thousand years of history in six
seven minutes starting from about 4th
century before christ when this temple
the temple of artemis a greek goddess
was built in Ephesus currently episode
is in Turkey at a time that was a Greek
economy sadly this is just the
reconstruction what the temple looks
like no one is completely sure that he
it really looked like that because
although it was one of the most
beautiful temples over ancient Greek
Greece this is all that remains of it
nowadays it was not destroyed by time by
weather earthquake or war it was
destroyed by the actions of one single
person this person wanted to remain
famous wanted to be known even for a bed
type of action and decided to destroy
the temple of his town his name was
herro status now 2,000 years later we
have less costly ways of achieve fame
and infamy about in 2007 a Facebook
group became famous 30 reasons why a
garage akali tonight we're girls and
cells were uploading photos of
themselves in various states of
drunkenness interestingly in about two
thousand seven there was also the famous
beacon debate when Facebook tried to do
quite aggressive social marketing
probably came and quaint to what is
being done nowadays just four years
later but many Facebook users create a
groups against the beacon and perhaps
some of the users who were uploading
photos of themselves to the first
reasons group maybe we're also joining
the users Facebook against beacon group
what I'm trying to say is that inside
each of us across Easter return
sculptures there are this need for
publicity and needs for privacy and they
are not in contradiction although they
are sometimes in conflict in economies
we describe these as a problem of
signaling you try to signal to the
marketplace the marketplace being your
peers information about you selectively
and indeed the economics of privacy
tries to understand the trade-offs
associated with these revelation or non
revelation the problem is that sometimes
we make wrong assumptions about our own
ability of calculating the cost and
benefits in the future discounted of
current disclosure no disclosures in
fact the problems of a semi-automatic
information not only how your data is
you is used province of boundaries
analogy province of cognitive behavioral
biases may affect our decisions let me
give you one example this is study we
did a few years ago but I like it
because it's a very intuitive
explanation of how our valuation for
privacy can dramatically change when we
change the famous frame of a problem we
went to a shopping mall outside
Pittsburgh we asked people to proceed
participate in a survey the survey was a
decoy in reality the experiment started
at the end of the survey when subjects
were given a payment a ten-dollar card
that would allow them to make runs
actions without being tracked other
subjects instead got a $12 card they
were told they discard the transactions
done with this card will be tracked back
to their identities okay so randomized
experiment two different groups the
interesting things is what happened
about 40 seconds later to the subjects
we were given a ten-dollar card with all
them hey by the way do you want to swap
your 10 dollah card for a $12 trackable
card two dollars more valuable less
privacy to the $12 subject we asked them
reverse do you want to swap your $12
card for a ten dollar car two dollar
less valuable but more privacy
this is probably over endowment in
economical behavior economic terms and
what we found was that for the subjects
who started from the ten-dollar card one
of the two fifty-two percent kept their
card said my data is more valuable than
two dollars the subjects who started
from the twelve dollar card less than
ten percent chose the pathetic card so
this kind of problems they cannot
difficulties we have in evaluating the
value of our personal data and therefore
how much revealing to protect are only
going to get worse because the
technologies we develop make it more and
more likely that you can infer very
sensitive data starting from non
sensitive information such as your face
in study that we presented this summer
we started from a face we compared face
a pathogen anonymous to data from
identify databases of faces such as
LinkedIn or Facebook then we found there
for a probabilistically speaking
presumptive name for the anonymous face
from the name we found a more
information online about a person from
more information online about a bad
person we made additional inferences
such as in our case Social Security
numbers which means and now you can
connect Social Security numbers directly
to an anonymous face and in fact we try
to do it also added as a demo in real
time on a mobile device using cloud
computing you between computing
statistical if the identification in all
of these so this this is the story of
the privacy in augmented reality hence
the title of my talk up until ear and up
until now we've been thinking about
privacy online in privacy of line these
two word are about to merge what we did
as a proof of concept as a demo now is
going to become 5 10 15 years out a
world where anyone can look at you any
first sensitive information about you
replacing or perhaps complementing what
as human being have evolved through
thousands of years hundreds of thousands
of years to do based on our gas filling
complementing that through technology
which sometimes may be correct sometimes
may be wrong in both cases it may be a
little bit creepy now some people say
that in this world where anonymity may
disappear and where disclosure will be
extreme because everyone will have to
disclose so much will achieve a new
equilibrium where even without privacy
things are going to be good but let me
close with some experiment which
suggests that maybe things maybe not so
optimistic I told you so mr. a mr. a is
a story that we told our subjects in
other randomized experiment we assign
our students to fight different
conditions they write different versions
of the story of mystery in what we're
sure mr. a was born in San Diego went to
school got vaccinations gostosa green
amber went to college graduated move to
you soon nothing too bad nothing to buy
the best mr. a and we asked our subjects
how much do you like mystery whether you
would like to work with mr. ray what we
were interested is how people discount
good or bad information about others
depending on whether this information is
presented as being fresh very recent or
old so in the other experimental
conditions our subjects were some
randomly assigned to we add some
information that was not included in the
initial case even all the conditions we
said mr. a just before graduation found
the purse with ten thousand dollars in
cash brought it back to the police the
rightful owner God Becker money and this
up in 12 months ago in the other case we
reported this as opening five years ago
in another case mr. a did not bring back
the money the rightful owner didn't get
back the cash and is a painful months
ago and finally in the last case mr. a
didn't have been black the money the
rightful owner didn't get to the cash
this up in five years ago so do you want
to know what happens in terms of how mr.
a is liked when when he brings back the
money and we say this up in 12 months
ago mr. a is like much much more than
the baseline virtual mystery so this act
is powerful when we say that is up in
five years ago no significant difference
whatsoever from the baseline scenario
when we say it did something bad regard
that so when these information is
reported a referring to this information
negative negatively affect miss array
the story here is that if the internet
makes it difficult
to forget our brain makes it difficult
to forgive thank you okay we have time
for a couple of questions there must be
questions very private audience okay
although I his crap it's a question the
question is a very good question how do
I if I under if I heard it correctly how
do I live my life online so i will quote
something as i applied behavior Kaname
to the field sometimes I applied
behavior cannot extreme itself so I'll
sighs offical the rational ignorance
sometimes you decide irrationally to
remain ignorant about something by
extension sometimes irrational decide
not to act to the fence something so you
can imagine a Cartesian diagram of
effort and the cost-benefit the extreme
scenario there is living like the
Unabomber you don't use any electronic
device ever you don't communicate with
others through normal means and you know
what you can still be found eventually
in the other scenario you would live
your life is an open book constantly I
tend to be kind of like here but I
realized that you cannot really live a
completely outside the you can't win a
longer availability or not not share
information wee wee wee bear what I call
a privacy externality those of us who
want to protect privacy realize that is
very costly to do so hey because you may
not have the technology be because when
everybody else is provided information
you're not providing information may
signal that you have terrible negative
information about you that you want to
either yes but my video will be with the
my face will be blurred the front the
video hahaha ok you thanks
thanks Alessandro again and beer finish
off this apana who will be led by ethan
Zuckerman from just around the corner
alley fur Touissant to introduce the
panelists and i will try to leave it to
him to